في تقديرك الى اين ستقود التفاعلات
الجاريه من ضغوط من عائلات واهالي الاسرى
في قطاع غزه وكذلك الخلافات التي بدا
واضحا انها تكتنف عمل الجانب السياسي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومجلس وزراء
الحرب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولجمهور
مشاهدي الحقيقه بان الخلافات الان بين
مكونات القياده السياسيه في اسرائيل على
اشدها وربما الخلاف الان الدائر حول ما
بعد الحرب هو الخلاف الاشد ولنفهم عمق هذا
الخلاف اللي نعرف او نحن بحاجه لان نعرف
لماذا اصر بنفير و سموتريتش على ابعاد
بيني جانس ورد صلاحيه
مناقشه ما بعد الحرب الى المجلس
الحرب مجلس الحرب المصغر وليس الموس
وبالتالي هنا يرون بان بيني جانس يريد ان
تكون للسلطه الفلسطينيه او للفلسطينيين
دور في اداره قطاع غزه وبالتالي هذا في
نظرهم يعزز وجود كيان فلسطيني فكره
سموتريتش وبنج فير عن قطاع غزه هي تتكون
من ثلاثه اركان يعني كما يقال في اللغه
العبريه ل خبوش لتيا شيف ل جارش بمعنى
اننا نحتل ونطرد ونستو
هذه هي الفكره التي يدعمونها ويدعمون بشده
وبالتالي اي حديث عن وجود فلسطيني اعاده
مجتمع قطاع غزه الى ما كان عليه هو حديث
مرفوض بالنسبه اليهما هم يدركون بان بني
جاند سيسير في هذا المنحى وبالتالي هم
يريدون السيطره الكامله على قطاع غزه حزب
سموتريتش نظم منذ اسبوعين تقريبا او
اليهوديه الدينيه او التيار اليهودي
القومي
قام بعمل مؤتمر قبل اسبوعين لبحث
الاستيطان وعوده الاستيطان الى قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هذه هي فكرتهم وسيدافع عنها حتى
النهايه ومن ضمن ذلك هو ابعاد بني جانس
الوضع الان داخل السياسه الاسرائيليه
والمستوى السياسي في اسرائيل متوتر جدا من
جهه نتنياهو يريد اطاله امد هذه الحرب
ليبتعد عن لجان التحقيق من جهه اخرى ب
جانس لا يريد ان يرث هذه الحرب عن نتنياهو
من بعد نتنياهو وبالتالي هو
يتركه سموتريتش وبينغ فير يزاود على
نتنياهو اكثر واكثر ليظهرا على يمينه
ويقنع اليمين الاسرائيلي بانهما هم
المتشدد وهم صاحبا الطرح الكوري وبالتالي
الموقف الان معقد
ومتخبطه السياسي الاسرا هو هو معقد معقد
لكن لابد من ان هناك احدهم يعني هناك
احدهم يقول ماذا بعد الحرب بالنسبه ليس
بالنسبه لغزه كما امر نتنياهو بوقف مناقشه
هذه المساله ولكن بالنسبه لنتنياهو نفسه
يعني الحرب هذه التي يريد نتنياهو اطالتها
باكبر او باطول فتره ممكنه لابد انها
ستنتهي في يوم ما ماذا يعد نتنياهو لهذا
اليوم يعني نتنياهو يعد لهذا اليوم
سيناريو من اسود السيناريوهات التي يمكن
ان تمر بها دوله الاحتلال اولا نتنياهو
بدا باعداد عشرات ومئات الوثائق التي
استولى عليها وتحفظ عليها وهذا ب بضمن
قضيه رفعتها مؤسسات المجتمع المدني او
حركه مراقبه الحكم والسلطه ضد نتنياهو
بانه استولى على وثائق من ديوان رئاسه
الوزراء
ليستخدمها لتبرئه ساحته ويتلاعب بنتائج
التح تحقيق هذا اولا ثانيا نتنياهو بدا
منذ الان باتهام الجيش واتهام الاجهزه
الامنيه بالتقصير وحتى الان يرفض نتنياهو
ان يعترف بمسؤوليته عن ما حدث في السابع
من اكتوبر ما الذي يعنيه هذا هذا يعني انه
لاول مره في تاريخ دوله الاحتلال يكون
الجيش محط اتهام اذا اردنا ان نفهم مجتمع
الاحتلال مجتمع
الاحتلال فيه الكثير من الانقسامات لكنه
مجمع حول الجيش الجيش هو قدس اقداس الشارع
الاسرائيلي والان نتنياهو يخطط لاتهام
الجيش بالتقصير ومعنى ذلك بانه سيخوض حرب
اعلاميه سيشوه فيها صوره الجيش يتهم
بالتقصير يتهم بالغفله يتهم بعدم الجاهزيه
وا مما ادى الى السابع من اكتوبر ايضا
هناك مساله مهمه جدا يعدها نتن وهي
استعداء شارع اليمين او جمهور اليمين على
جمهور اليسار قبل اربعه ايام قام
اي يئير نتنياهو ابن نتنياهو بنشر تغريده
يتهم فيها الجيش بانه غض الطرف عن ما حدث
في السابع من اكتوبر وعن المعلومات التي
تدفقت الى الاجهزه الامنيه حول السابع من
اكتوبر لاسقاط والده كون ان الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه ذات اغلبيه يساريه
نتنياهو يمهد بذلك لنظريه المؤامره
وبالتالي تاليف جمهور اليمين حوله وتكوين
نواه صلبه من المعتقدين بنظريه المره
وهؤلاء سيتعاملون بعنف وبشده مع خصومهم
السياسيين